la conmoción continúa en Memphis tras la
muerte de la afroamericano taller
Nichols cuando estaba bajo custodia
cinco oficiales de policía
el jueves el fiscal del Estado anunció
la investigación por cargos de homicidio
y están bajo arresto
el gran Jurado presentó acusaciones
contra los cinco con los mismos cargos y
nos habíamos reunido previamente con la
familia de tyre Nichols para repasar
Cuáles iban a hacer estos cargos
Aunque cada uno de los cinco individuos
desempeñó un papel diferente las
acciones de todos ellos provocaron la
muerte de Michaels y todos son
responsables
en tanto que el departamento policial de
Memphis que los desvinculó el sábado
prometió colaborar en el caso
Esto no es sólo una falla profesional es
una falta de humanidad básica hacia otra
persona
este incidente fue atroz imprudente e
inhumano cuando se publique el video en
los próximos días lo verán por ustedes
mismos
el abogado de uno de los acusados
criticó la intervención Federal en la
investigación y pidió que el caso no se
condicione por el dolor de la comunidad
no quiero que haya ningún prejuicio en
su contra cuando se trata de un tribunal
de Justicia como miembro de la comunidad
entiendo la necesidad de saber qué
sucedió Entonces es un delicado acto de
equilibrio que la fiscalía va a tener
que emprender
vigilias y protestas se suscitaron en
las últimas horas en un caso que apenas
comienza a desarrollarse